und wie das aber an der grenze aktuell
aussieht das haben unsere kollegen sich
in den vergangenen stunden in den
nächten einmal angeschaut dort vor allen
dingen an eine grenze von brandenburg
nach polen rüber unser kollege peter
wilke war in der nacht unterwegs
bild auf der flüchtlings- und die grenze
von polen nach deutschland es ist
freitagabend 20 uhr fahrzeugkontrolle in
frankfurt oder die polizei durchleuchtet
lastwagen kleintransporter
gesucht werden schlepper und illegale
migranten in dieser nacht hier ohne
erfolg wir fahren also weiter richtung
süden in die grenzstadt hier in dieser
nacht keine kontrollen
es ist 52 mitten in der nacht da
passiert es wir sehen vier junge männer
sie laufen schnell über die grenze nach
deutschland geschafft vier männer aus
dem jemen zu fuß nach oben gekommen so
erzählen sie es wir haben einen krieg in
unserem land wir können dort nicht mehr
leben die männer sie kamen über ägypten
dort kauften sie sich ein flugticket
nach minsk und aus der lukaschenko
hauptstadt ist an fast 300 kilometer
richtung litauen zu fuß man kann nicht
wieder zurück über kamen nichts zu essen
oder zu trinken oder andere hilfe in
belarus treiben sie jeden wie tiere in
richtung liter
dreimal so oft versuchten sie es rein
nach litauen in die eu doch die
grenzschützer dort bringen sie
zurückliegt zurück wieder raus aus
europa sie nahmen und unser geld auch
elektroschocker wollen gegen uns
eingesetzt ein brutales katz und maus
spiel im grenzgebiet mehr als einen
monat dauert es für die vier männer
gefangen in den wäldern zwischen litauen
und bethaus niemand will sie sie
beschließen es über die polnische grenze
zu versuchen die mögen und plötzlich
diese menschen brauchen hilfe und die
können wir nur in deutschland bekommen
diesmal klappt es rein nach mit einem
schlepper der fährt die vier männer mit
dem auto bis an die deutsche grenze ihr
plan jetzt weiter nach berlin doch
anbahnung von oben werden die vier
gestoppt ein kilometer weiter
mit und eider geschafft hier auf
deutschen staatstheorie thorium bis zum
bahnhof ihren google von iris wollten
sie eigentlich weiter nach berlin die
bundespolizei hat sie jetzt hier aber
aufgegriffen die daten aufgenommen
sofern sie denn vorhanden sind und wird
sie jetzt in das nächste sammeln zentrum
in eisenhüttenstadt bringen eigentlich
wollten sie bis nach berlin doch für die
vier männer zählt hauptsache sie sind in
deutschland
hat ehrgeiz warum haben es die vier
männer ihrer einschätzung nach überhaupt
rein nach google geschafft also warum
treffen die da in der nacht zuerst auf
unserem bild kollegen peter wilke und
nicht zuerst auf einen ihrer kollegen ja
das liegt daran weil deutschland sich
nach wie vor weigert bei der
europäischen kommission die
grenzkontrollen zu beantragen nach polen
dann wäre dort eine welt gestanden eine
streife gestanden die genau die
sichtkontrollen gemacht hätten im
übrigen hatte ich das ja auch vorgestern
schon medial verkündet bin mir auch sehr
sicher dass wir den schleuser der den
toten migranten hinten im lkw hat er
hätten dingfest machen können wenn wir
ganz kontrollen an der grenze gehabt
hätten beim mal keiner haben und die
menschen ersten kilometer weiter im
landesinnern aufgegriffen werden durch
die bundespolizei dann bringen wir sie
nur noch in die aufenthalts
zentren und das war es dann herr villa
würden sie deswegen sagen es fehlt halt
ans grenzkontrolle grenzkontrollen auch
von deutschland nach polen wir schauen
uns nochmal an biester in der situation
außer in der nacht in guben da sind die
vier männer nämlich aus dem jemen über
diese brücke übergelaufen und direkt
dort befindet sich die polizeistation
wir sehen dass hier an dem an dem schild
draußen das heißt da laufen die vorbei
und die beamten sozusagen schauen weg in
dem moment können auch gar nichts tun
aber jetzt ist es zu spät die vier haben
es geschafft obwohl sie in polen in der
eu gelandet sind sind sie am ende in
deutschland in einem erstaufnahmelager
nämlich in dem fall in eisenhüttenstadt
würden sie sich wünschen an den grenzen
ja kontrollieren zu können
also es geht nicht darum was ich wünsche
sondern das ist die freizügigkeit die
wir uns alle wünschen an die wir uns
schon seit jahren gewöhnt haben aber
diese freizügigkeit hängt von
voraussetzungen ab nämlich von einem
wirksamen schutz der eu-außengrenzen in
der tat ist es so dass sehen wir nicht
nur im bereich sozusagen litauen polen
sondern auch gerade in griechenland und
im südraum der europäischen union das
die außengrenze alles andere als wirksam
geschützt ist und solange sie so löchrig
ist wie ein schweizer käse kann man
nicht auf dauern grenzkontrollen
vermeide steht weiß er bereits im jahre
2019 insofern ist ganz klar wenn es
jetzt nicht zu wirksamen geschlossenen
und entschlossenen maßnahmen der
europäischen union kommt nämlich
stichwort visa-freiheit sanktionen gegen
die fluggesellschaften beziehungsweise
auch die unterstützung beispielsweise
die terror und polen bei der
grenzsicherung
einmal alle ihre ganze routine aus